hey guys came here bringing you news
that square enix is teasing a brand-new
game via the medium of twitch but what
could it be it's probably their sex the
publisher is teased as stream via its
official Twitter account inviting fast
and join them on Twitch for a unique
three-day interactive experience from
one of our Western Studios project ckp
or can't kill progress will eventually
lead to reveal through a project from
one of said Western studios show that
pretty much points to a new Deus Ex or
hitman or more likely Deus Ex during the
first day the loop stream is shown CCTV
footage of the unnamed prisoner marching
up and down his cell this cuts the
footage of him cursing his captors and
later shows and sleeping in one scene
he's also wearing a snazzy prisoners
jacket before it's taken by a man who
appears to have an Augmented arm twitch
stream viewers can vote for what our
incarcerated companions should do at
various points such as deciding on
whether he should give up an address
during an interrogation the good folks
over at red are trying to link the
footage to the deus ex series offering a
breakdown of the graphic elements fonts
and cryptic hints from the stream other
fans have noted that Square Enix had
trademarked the name Deus Ex mankind
divided back in 2014 so a sci-fi fans
are you excited for a new Deus Ex let me
know in the comments down below
preferably using your augmented robot
limb to type the message thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more against
bar news
you